témoin de la guerre au haut karabagh la
communauté internationale s'organise
lentement après plus d'une semaine de
combats meurtriers et toujours aucune
issue au conflit
l'heure est à la coordination des forces
diplomatiques avec pour fer de lance la
coprésidence du groupe de minsk
créée il ya près de trente ans lors de
la première crise du haut karabagh ce
lundi les ministres des affaires
étrangères des trois pays coprésidents
du groupe ont appelé à la fin des
combats tout en condamnant les frappes
sur les populations civiles
les représentants des pays coprésidents
du groupe de minsk de l'osce cee
condamne avec la plus grande fermeté les
escalades de violence inédite et
dangereuse survenus dans et en dehors de
la zone de conflit du haut karabagh les
attaques récentes qui aurait visé des
installations civiles et le caractère
disproportionné de telles attaques
constituent une menace inacceptable pour
la stabilité de la région
les ministres appellent une fois de plus
les parties au conflit à accepter un
cessez le feu immédiat et sans condition
en visite en turquie
le secrétaire général de l'otan a lui
aussi appelé à la fin des hostilités
entre les deux camps ankara de son côté
qui fait aussi partie du groupe de minsk
continue de prendre fait et cause pour
bakou oui a dit leekens nous sommes
profondément inquiet de l'escaladé
hostilités ce qui est parti doivent
immédiatement cesser de se battre et
trouver une voie vers une résolution
pacifique
j'attends de la turquie qu'elle use de
son influence considérable pour calmer
les tensions
enfin on n'ose à la soucoupe tout le
monde en particulier l'otan devrait
appeler l'arménie à se retirer afin
d'avoir une solution à ce problème dans
le cadre du droit international et des
résolutions du conseil de sécurité des
nations unies et de l'intégrité du
territoire de l'azerbaïdjan
il n'y a pas d'autre solution à ce
problème mais aucune des iraniens et
israéliens ont également [ __ ] pour une
résolution pacifique à ce conflit
mais toutes ces voies internationales
n'ont toujours pas convaincu les deux
belligérants de déposer les armes